[Musique]
il tout le monde est du même avis
que vous soyez le commande
vous aller sur la lune
le premier homme sur la lune ça va être
un sacré voyage
tu es sûr c'est une aventure qui brille
chez ton père va aller sur la lune notre
mission est si difficile
elle exige un tel niveau d'avancées
technologiques qu'il va falloir repartir
de zéro
baby danse et une belle bête ça va être
une vraie bombe atomique si ça explose
il on a eu un problème le module n'est
pas assez sûr
il est vivant j'suis pas sûr de pouvoir
tenir très longtemps dit il
c'est pas facile à lire
et sont morts neil il faut qu'on échoue
ici si on veut pas jouer là où et à quel
prix
c'est un peu tard pour se poser la
question neil c'est peut-être la
dernière fois que les garçons tout voir
est ce que quelqu'un un couteau suisse
un couteau suisse c'est une blague
tu crois que tu veux revenir à la maison
on a bien l'intention de revenir de
sédition mais c'est pas sûr
[Musique]
décollage
on a un gros problème
on contrôle la situation
contre les rien du tout
[Musique]